[Musik]
live aus köln der presseclub mit jörg
schönenborn
herzlich willkommen schön dass sie dabei
sind an diesem sonntag wir sprechen
heute über ein problem das uns seit
langer zeit vorhergesagt wurde auch das
ausmaß ist eigentlich recht präzise
geschrieben und doch scheinen wir es so
lange ignoriert zu haben bis wir jetzt
im alltag immer wieder mit der nase
darauf gestoßen werden ich spreche über
arbeitskräftemangel den wir wirklich
gerade an jeder ecke erleben die
fahrpläne von bus und bahn sind
ausgedünnt weil es keine fahrerinnen und
fahrer gibt regale im supermarkt nicht
nur leer weil rohstoffe fehlen sondern
auch die lkw fahrer ja und die bäckerei
um die ecke das gasthaus am abend hat
die öffnungszeiten verkürzt überall
fehlt personal und das ist nur die
spitze des eisbergs besonders schlimm
ist es in gesundheitswesen auf dem bau
im handwerk in der statistik der offenen
stellen ist die zahl so hoch wie noch
nie seit der wiedervereinigung und wenn
wir nicht schnell gute ideen haben wie
wir diese arbeitskräfte problem lösen
dann kostet es nicht nur nerven sondern
auch wachstum und wohlstand unser thema
heute personal not überall schwere
hypothek für unsere wirtschaft und ich
freue mich auf diese gäste stephan palla
garn ist wieder bei uns freier
journalist unter anderem für christ und
welt kraut reporter den bayerischen
rundfunk herzlich willkommen ich freue
mich auf christian rickens er ist
textchef bahn handelsblatt und bei uns
diese woche wieder ulrike herrmann
wirtschaftsredakteurin bei der
tageszeitung und herzlich willkommen
maike rademaker heute freie journalistin
lange zeit redakteurin bei der financial
times deutschland dann pressesprecherin
des dgb das müssen wir dazu sagen und
jetzt gerade marca
schreiben sie und sprechen frei für
verschiedene medien schön dass sie da
sind ich habe es gesagt so im alltag
gibt es doch manchmal das gefühl gerade
wenn wir auf die flughäfen gucken moment
mal was ist da plötzlich passiert warum
überrascht uns das wie ein blitz aus
heiterem himmel ja das ist ungefähr so
plötzlich wie weihnachten da weiß man
zwei wochen vorher bis zwei wochen
vorher auch nicht dass gleich
weihnachten ist es wird seit zehn jahren
ungefähr davor gewarnt und den über zehn
jahren davor gewarnt dass die
demografische entwicklung so zunehmen
wird das immer mehr fachkräfte fehlen
ich kann mich erinnern dass ich 2008 mal
mit einem hotel telefoniert habe in der
mecklenburgischen seenplatte die mir
sagten wir kriegen keine auszubildenden
mehr das ist jetzt 14 jahre her ich kann
mich erinnern dass ursula von der leyen
als arbeitsministerin mal gesagt hat wir
müssen das erfassen das wird auch jetzt
relativ gut gefasst klar ich bin die
krone war schon auf jetzt hat corona
noch mal dramatisch verschärft also die
korona krankheit dann die fehlende
zuwanderung wir bräuchten eigentlich
mehr zu änderungen leute kommen nicht
mehr zu uns und jetzt ist das desaster
da ja herr rickens warum so plötzlich
also wenn man darüber spricht im alltag
ist die frage wo sind die plötzlich alle
hin ja die meisten sind nie geboren
worden das ist glaube ich die antwort
und parade magath ja völlig recht also
ich würde sagen zehn jahre ist noch
untertrieben eigentlich ist es 30 40
jahre lang absehbar gewesen und das
eigentlich verblüffende ist ja das ist
wir haben immer von einem
fachkräftemangel geredet und er wurde
uns immer prognostiziert und dann
sollten die computer experten aus aller
welt zu uns kommen also inzwischen reden
wer war ein arbeitskräftemangel bis
hinunter der arbeitgeberpräsident hat
uns gerade erzählt er findet in seiner
fabrik noch nicht mal mehr leute die
kartons aufschneiden um ware auszupacken
also selbst auf den ball in aller
simpelsten tätigkeiten gibt es
inzwischen einen enormen mangel an
paraden ist es nur die wahrnehmung dass
uns dass plötzlich so ins auge springt
ja absolut ich kann den beinen
vorrednerin und vorräten an
weil pflichten dass wir in diese
demografische lage kommen werden das
wissen wir seit 40 jahren das ist ja gut
prognostiziert pillenknick etc
dass wir schon ein existenzielles
fachkräftemangel oder ein
arbeitskräftemangel problem haben das
haben uns die experten im
gesundheitswesen schon ganz lange
erzählt und dargestellt wir wissen von
ganz ganz vielen pädiatrie
kinderstationen in krankenhäusern die
voll ausgestattet sind aber die menschen
fehlen wir wissen von verzweifelten ober
und chefärzte die sagen wir müssen
familien weg schicken wir wissen dass
das schicksal dieser kinder sehr
ungewiss ist weil wir niemanden haben
der sie betreut intensiv betten in
corona waren nicht aktiv weil das
pflegeperson genau das uns daher denke
ich dass es überhaupt nicht überraschend
wir haben nur sehr lange nicht
hingeschaut in freimann die
bundesregierung hat diese woche auf ein
sonderproblem reagiert nämlich das chaos
an den flughäfen da soll es jetzt
möglich seien kurzfristig arbeitskräfte
für einige monate einzufliegen
anzulernen herzubekommen auch an sie die
frage wo sind die plötzlich alle hin und
warum springt uns das so ins auge also
ich glaube jetzt dass diese ganze
flughafen in die serie noch mal ein
sonderproblem ist das sehr viel auch mit
krone zu tun hat also ich meine wir
waren ja alle dabei ab märz 2020 konnten
die flugzeuge nicht mehr fliegen und
zwar weltweit und das hat auch weltweit
das muss man jetzt mal sagen enorme
verluste bei den fluggesellschaften
hinterlassen also die haben ungefähr
verluste von 200 milliarden gemacht
allein die lufthansa hatte verluste von
über 10 milliarden gemacht und dann
haben sie den fehler gemacht aber finde
ich jetzt menschlich verständlich ist
also ich möchte jetzt mich ja nicht über
die
flughafenchefs erheben also man hat dann
die idee gehabt okay wir haben diese
milliarden-verluste die dann auch nicht
vom staat getragen das müssen die
gesellschaften selbst wieder einspielt
dann kann die natürlich auf die idee
okay jetzt sparen wir personal nicht es
gab zwar kurzarbeiter programme aber
gleichzeitig gab es ebenso freistellung
programme bei der lufthansa also signal
an die beschäftigten war wir sind froh
wenn ihr geht und viele hatten die idee
gut ich gehe jetzt auch denn es gab ja
andere es anderswo auch gleichzeitig
expandierenden branche zum beispiel alle
wir waren dabei werden krone haben im
internet bestellt also brauchten diese
liefert neue leute und sehr viele von
dem bodenpersonal sind jetzt bei den
lieferdienst nocke und gekommen nicht
zurück so und jetzt sitzen sie da und
haben kein personal jahr der größte teil
unseres publikums wird diesen sommer
nicht in urlaub fliegen aber ich sag mal
jeder kennt jemanden und hat die
geschichte von nachbarn oder freunden
mit klappt das und befüllt stunden
vorher muss ich am flughafen seien
kriegen denn dieses problem noch in den
griff diesen sommer es scheint ja dann
die freiheit man gerade gesagt hat auch
spezielle gründe zu haben also ich
glaube man kann schon vieles tun und
jetzt kurzfristig arbeitskräfte
anzuwerben ist natürlich genau diese
kurzfrist maßnahme um irgendwie diesen
sommer zu überstehen
ich glaube langfristig müssen sich
gerade fluggesellschaften und flughäfen
überlegen wie sie
rational rationeller arbeiten mehr
automatisieren diese prozesse an
flughäfen wir kennen das alle sind ja
wirklich gewöhnungsbedürftig und man
denkt oft so geht das nicht irgendwie
effizienter und ich glaube da ist auch
tatsächlich in dem bereich viel versäumt
worden weil man irgendwie sich darauf
verlassen hat man hat ja arbeitskraft
arbeitskraft ist tendenziell billig man
muss gar nicht so groß nachdenken wie
man vielleicht dinge
automatisiert effizienter gestalten
ich glaube dass das das chaos an den
flughäfen diesen sommer nicht gelöst
werden kann also die idee 2000 türkische
kolleginnen und kollegen reinzuholen im
august einzusetzen
ist erstens zu spät zweitens frage ich
mich wenn sie dann im august anfangen
schicken wir die dann im september
wieder zurück und wie ist das mit diesen
ganzen prüfungen der der
sicherheitsvorkehrungen die gemacht
werden müssen also das ist ne das ist
eine lösung die passt überhaupt nicht
dazu ich fürchte wir werden durch dieses
flugchaos einfach durch müssen oder aber
vielleicht noch in den betrieben also in
den boden verkehrsbetrieben bei der
sicherheit nachfragen gibt effizienz
lücken können wir noch schnell was
digitalisieren können wir koffer früher
holen und zu kleine lösung aber diese
2000 leute werden das nicht machen
ich stimme ihnen vollkommen zu müssen
über die optimierung von prozessketten
nachdenken über automatisierung über
effizienzsteigerungen ich habe nur das
gefühl dass in deutschland der hang
existiert sich an so magischen denkens
entlang zu hangeln
es gibt dann häufig dieses schlagwort
technologieoffenheit oder da kommt dann
schon so viel in pará eine innovation
ich
wenn ich in die bücher schauen dann höre
ich dass seit den 70er jahren in der
automobilindustrie dass dann die roboter
kaum und quasi die menschliche
arbeitskraft ersetzen werden das aber
nicht passiert und dort wo digitalisiert
wird oder wo transformation stattfinden
werden möglicherweise in der innenstadt
läden geschlossen aber dafür brauchen
wir wiederum menschen als paket bohnen
oder auslieferungsfahrer die das halt
tun und gerade im bereich
lkw hören wir seit sehr sehr lange zeit
das ist der erste beruf der in gefahr
gerät weil dort automatisiert wird das
autonome fahren kommt und zweitens kommt
und aus der industrie heraus kam dann
immer auch die ansage ja möglicherweise
können wir diesen fachkräftemangel oder
diesen arbeitskräftemangel dadurch
kompensieren das automatisiert wird nur
das dauert und an anderer stelle
entstehen betraf bevor wir zu den saison
komfort hermann noch ja ja ich glaube es
gibt noch eine lösung die noch gar nicht
auf dem tisch ist die aber von dem chef
der von ryanair schon ganz klar
angesprochen wird nämlich fliegen wird
einfach teurer also wenn man nicht mehr
alle passagiere transportieren kann dann
erhöht man die preise was für die
fluggesellschaften selbst super ist mit
weniger personal macht man mehr gewinnen
und dann kann eben nicht mehr jeder
fliegen so dann hat man natürlich eine
verteilungsfrage weil das ist ja klar
wer bei hohen preisen nicht mehr fliegen
kann aber das ist sozusagen die
betriebswirtschaftliche lösung steht
dann eben nicht mehr jedem zur verfügung
ende der durchsage so und das werden wir
glaube ich jetzt ganz oft erleben dass
preise steigen dass auch löhne steigen
natürlich aber preise steigen auch und
das angebot wird geschrumpft danke für
die erste runde
danke ihnen sie verfolgen und diese doch
auch wieder in den livestreams bei
tagesschau.de presseclub die habe auch
viele rückmeldungen schon gelesen gehe
ich gleich darauf ein machen sie bitte
weiter und das hilft uns also ich fasse
mal die erste runde zusammen ist kommt
so plötzlich wie weihnachten sagt plathe
marca
wir haben eine grafik vorbereitet die
demografische entwicklung das ist so die
altersentwicklung der gesellschaft
aufzeigt da sieht man auf einen blick
wenn sie mal ab dies ganz alte segment
gucken wie sich der anteil von 1990 auf
ja es noch ein bisschen hin 2060
ungefähr verdoppeln wird also das ist
jetzt keine überraschung
wir haben dieses sonderproblem flughäfen
sozusagen das klammern werfen mal aus
weil es wirklich nur ein teil in der
bevölkerung betrifft aber die kernfrage
über die ich mit ihnen diskutieren will
ist wie lösen wir das problem nachdem es
ja offenbar schon versäumnisse gibt uns
unseren arbeitsmarkt unsere wirtschaft
darauf vorzubereiten
jetzt sind schon stichworte gefallen
automatisierung aber das was finde ich
auf der hand liegt parade marca das habe
ich diese woche auch gedacht als die
neuen arbeitslosenzahlen verkündet
wurden
in unseren sendungen in unseren apps
wenn wir die nachrichten lesen auf der
einen seite die meldungen über den
dramatischen personalmangel und die
arbeitslosigkeit ist mit 2,4 millionen
relativ gering 5,2 prozent da haben wir
ganz andere werte über viele jahre
gehabt aber die vermutung ist doch dass
da 2,4 millionen menschen hinter stecken
die nicht arbeiten das finde ich und da
bin ich ganz bei astrid brand die das
auf twitter gefragt hat warum kümmert
man sich da nicht zuerst um unsere
arbeitslosen also das eine ist dass
viele arbeitslose nicht unbedingt
bedeutet dass die irgendwie lange suchen
es gibt dabei eine vollbeschäftigung so
ein prozentsatz von 3 300 es ist schon
voll beschäftigen das ist der normale
satz an menschen die aussteigen
einsteigen aussteigen einstellung aus
wie im bus sind ja nicht immer die
gleichen leute im bus drin insofern muss
man aufpassen wenn man die zahl dass die
wartezeit beim umsteigen qua sozusagen
und das zweite ist dass man drei prozent
das inzwischen 24 und 3 erst
vollbeschäftigung also ich weiß dass in
eichstätt flughafen in münchen 24
prozent gilt als vollbeschäftigung da
kriegen sie kaum noch jemanden rein und
raus ist wirklich schwierig das zweite
ist der bäcker in mecklenburg vorpommern
oder das hotel im becken bevor man hat
nichts davon wenn in berlin das ist ja
doch einige stunden oder irgendwo anders
ein arbeitsloser sitzt er sagt naja bei
war jetzt nicht nach mecklenburg
vorpommern dann möchte ich jetzt nicht
arbeiten das matching alle leute passen
entweder von der qualifikation oder eben
vom amateur nicht zusammen und deswegen
ist ein fachkräftemangel auch bei hoher
arbeitslosigkeit durchaus möglich weil
sich das in regionen statt land
vollkommen unterschiedlich verteilt und
die zueinander finden zu lassen ist ein
größeres problem da muss man mobilität
fördern qualifikation fördern auch
vielleicht mal hingehen und sagen dann
machen wir bei qualifikation mehr und da
müssen wir mehr machen sprich hohe
arbeitslosenzahl
viel suche ist nicht unbedingt kann man
nicht einfach zusammenführen und sagen
dann ist es gelöst meinungen dazu aber
ich glaube man muss also zur wahrheit
gehört auch also das stimmt absolut dass
mit der mit der vollbeschäftigung oder
eben schon relativ nah dran sind ich
glaube
740.000 haben wir im arbeitslosengeld 1
also leute die weniger als ein jahr
arbeitslos sind und man muss leider
aussagen von denen die dann eben schon
länger als ein jahr arbeitslos sind
stehen halt viele dann doch nicht so
uneingeschränkt den arbeitsmarkt zur
verfügung wie wir das vielleicht gerne
hätten also da sind dann eben auch
menschen dabei mit gesundheitlichen
problemen mit mit sozialen problemen
wo man ehrlich sagen muss die kann man
nicht morgen aber was ist das denn für
eine statistik wenn menschen die krank
sind und nicht arbeiten können
mitgezählt werden
also wenn sie drei stunden arbeiten
können und zwar einfach mal generell
arbeiten ob sie jetzt da sind oder ob
sie an der kasse sitzen dann sind sie
erwerbsfähig nach einer sehr
umstrittenen definition was erwerbsfähig
ist da können sie lahm und im rollstuhl
sitzt immer noch erwerbs okay also ich
halte fest es sind sozusagen die
umsteiger die die statistik fällen es
sind menschen die nicht in münchen
wurden sollen in mecklenburg vorpommern
also nicht da wo sie gebraucht werden es
sind menschen die gesundheitlich
eingeschränkten anfragen dazu noch eine
zahl also 40 prozent aller hartz 4
empfänger also die ihre offiziell
erwerbsfähig sind sind gesundheitlich
schwer eingeschränkt das ist auch eine
zahl der bundesagentur für arbeit also
da sieht man schon dass ein reges recht
hat dass diese idee die zählen irgendwie
offiziell als erwerbsfähig weil sie
offiziell irgendwie drei stunden
arbeiten könnten das mit der realität in
den firmen und auch der arbeitgeber
nichts zu tun hat die bundesregierung
will jetzt sanktionen aussetzen wenn
bezieher von grundsicherung von hartz iv
termine nicht wahrnehmen also gab es
bisher sperger von geld da würden sie
sagen weil die sowieso keine chance
haben zu arbeiten ist das in ordnung
oder also ich würde sagen das ist ja
außerordentlich umstritten ob man die
sanktionen jetzt aussetzen soll oder
nicht aber die ganze maßnahme ist ja
befristet und das ist so im
koalitionsvertrag vorgesehen und das
finde ich jetzt okay dass man das mal
ausprobiert ob das tatsächlich nicht
genauso gut läuft wenn man nicht ständig
damit der drohkulisse droht weil das ist
ja gleichzeitig auch ein bisschen
würdelos für die arbeitslosen und sich
ständig mit dieser funktion daher
konfrontiert werden insofern bin ich
sehr dafür dass jetzt mal zu machen und
zu gucken wie es läuft ja ich sehe mir
klickt man die leute aber auch nicht in
arbeit indem man hingeht und sagt ich
sanktioniert dich um 30 40 50 prozent
runter und dann wirst du schon
irgendwann auf den trip kommen dass wir
jetzt arbeiten ist das ist also das ist
eine politische maßnahme aber die hat
jetzt mit fachkräfte arbeitskräftemangel
wenig zu tun ja also ich will noch
einmal gedanklich ein bisschen sortieren
also wir sprechen darüber wie wir das
problem dass wir geschrieben haben und
das zum teil dramatische ausmaße hat
lösen ich sag mal wir haben auf der auf
der liste die wir noch besprechen müssen
man kann vielleicht arbeit weg
automatisieren kam schon das stichwort
zuwanderung also wie kommen menschen zu
uns die arbeiten können werden zweites
thema aber ich wollte anfang mit dem
thema menschen in unserer gesellschaft
die vielleicht noch potenziale haben zu
arbeiten
drei große aspekte die seine ist
zuwanderungen das andere aber lassen sie
uns bei den genauen sie alle sagen immer
ich würde die drei heime kurz auf sind
das zweite ist bildungs und
teilhabechancen gerecht wird also hat
diesen punkt sind wir auch nicht viel
weitergekommen letzten 20 30 jahren das
dritte thema ist diskriminierung in der
arbeitswelt ja und wenn wir das thema
familiengründungen und wiedereinstieg in
den beruf nach einer erziehungszeit
haben dann muss ich sagen wenn wir uns
jetzt die pflege anschauen da gibt es
nachtschichten da gibt es
wechselschichten wie möchten sie das
machen mit einem kinderbetreuung system
wie es in deutschland vor herrscht was a
wahlweise nicht existiert oder wo die
kita um 14 uhr schließt oder sie gar
nicht wohnortnah ist und wenn sie
alleinerziehend sind es funktioniert
nicht da gibt es menschen die arbeiten
wollen die arbeitsfähig sind aber es
nicht können weil sie kinder pflegen
oder vielleicht irgendwie angehörige
pflegen und da haben wir an diesen
sekundär stellen im arbeitsmarkt in der
infrastruktur ganz ganz viel was wir
nachzuholen haben sekundär stellen heißt
also die kinderbetreuung blogs weisen
und dieses thema bildungs und
teilhabechancen da geht es um die
qualifizierung die erst qualifizierung
auch in die weiterqualifizierung wir
wissen dass beispielsweise ein beruf wie
ergotherapie da müssen sie sich ständig
fort und weiterbilden aber dass man sie
selber bezahlen das ist unglaublich
teuer ja und die einnahmen die sie haben
das steckt halt auch diese
investitionsausgaben nicht und da müssen
wir auch als gesellschaft besser werden
ich kenne auch eine große gruppe die
mehr arbeiten könnte das sind mehrere
hunderttausend wenn nicht millionen
frauen die vor allem in mini jobs
stecken also es gibt mehrere
hunderttausend frauen die ausschließlich
mini job machen weil sie vor allem auch
im ehegattensplitting das halt günstig
ist wenn man verdient es ist für sie
günstiger im minijob so ein bisschen
urlaub und hat dazu zu verdienen die
sind in der regel gut ausgebildet und
sie haben eine ausbildung und krabbeln
in diesen kleinen jobs drin gewann mal
gedacht als brücke in besseren job das
sind sie aber nicht sie sind in der
regel die brücke in die altersarmut für
frauen deswegen plädiere ich dafür statt
wie die koalition das gemacht hat
minijobs auszuweiten neben allen ernstes
dass auch noch gefördert jetzt mit dem
letzten koalitionsvertrag und schon
beschlossen die so einzuschränken dass
nur noch rentner rentnerin studierende
diese jobs machen und die frauen
zusammen mit einem abgeschafften
ehegattensplitting
auf den arbeitsmarkt recht haben so
können sie in einfachen worten erklären
ich habe den zusammenhang nicht ganz
verstanden also wenn ich
sag mal ist nicht brauche weil mein mann
oder eine frau verdient wir eigentlich
genug geld haben aber ich ein bisschen
dazuverdienen kann dafür keine oder kaum
steuern bezahlen muss warum ist das
schwierig das ehegattensplitting fördert
ehepaaren nicht familienvan der mann
genug verdient dann muss die frau nicht
arbeiten und wenn sie arbeiten geht und
sie im ehegatten bedingt dann bekommt
sie so wenig geld dadurch dass sie höher
besteuert wird als der mann okay das ist
für sie nicht attraktiv das heißt also
ihr plädoyer wer veränderung von
steuerrecht aber die idee ist frauen
verheiratete meist frauen die nicht
arbeiten weil es keinen anlass gibt es
ja das ist ein weg das ist ja letztlich
man muss das mal attraktiver macht nicht
zu arbeiten und da frage ich mich so ein
bisschen was für einer gesellschaft
wollen wir denn eigentlich in zukunft
leben also natürlich kann man
theoretisch jeden mangel an
arbeitskräften dadurch lösen dass wir
alle mehr arbeiten bis 69 hat die
bundesbank
sie sagen frauen aus dem mini jobs raus
das hat ja auch was damit zu tun ist
dass das leben das wir leben wollen wo
wir eben alle vollzeit arbeiten bis 67
69 oder wollen wir vielleicht irgend
einen smarteren weg gehen um dieses
kleine wesen ein ehegattensplitting ist
es so dass der normale steuerzahler
subventioniert was eine ehefrau nicht
arbeitet und wenn man jetzt feststellt
ist vielen aber arbeitskräfte dann ist
das allererste dass man sich doch fragt
als normaler steuerzahler an dich und
ich bin normale stoller jetzt
steuerzahler ritt warum soll ich denn
jetzt das modell ehefrau die zu hause
setzt subventionen
sehr dafür dass man das
ehegattensplitting muslim vor mir aus
einer mächtigkeit aus
geschlechtergerechtigkeit gründen ich
bin dagegen ist jetzt zu reformieren
nachdem man es 40 jahre lang wird
angeschaut hat wie ungerecht das ist
weil man sagt jetzt müssen die frauen
aber auch mal arbeiten hast du das ist
sowieso das
lassen sind lassen sie das splitting
okay ist ich habe es verstanden ist ein
punkt
harrisons hat den satz gesagt der jetzt
bei mir so ein bisschen nach tickt
wollen wir in einer gesellschaft leben
in der es unattraktiv gemacht wird nicht
zu arbeiten
einerseits ja wir haben in deutschland
gesellschaften gehabt wo es eine formale
oder es hat mal informelle pflicht zum
arbeiten gab auf der anderen seite ja
wenn wir soviel arbeit brauchen so viele
arbeitskräfte brauchen warum war das so
schlecht da ist also für das ist meine
persönliche meinung wieder einen begriff
von freiheit und individueller
selbstbestimmung meines lebens relativ
wenig zu tun hat natürlich muss man
irgendwie seinen lebensunterhalt
verdienen aber ich würde am liebsten
selber bestimmen ob ich jetzt mit 940 69
oder 89 in ruhestand gehe und ob ich
zehn 20 oder vielleicht auch 50 oder 60
stunden pro woche arbeite also ich jetzt
gern kann da nur sänger und dann also
wir haben ja in der politik über
jahrzehnte hinweg den arbeitsmarkt
liberalisiert und flexibilisiert was wir
aber in wirklichkeit getan haben ist den
arbeitgebern und den branchen
instrument in die hand zu geben um
arbeit zu flexibilisieren und das hat
dazu geführt dass wir leiharbeit haben
wir sind minijob geschichten dieses
verwertete rückkehrrecht in die vollzeit
nach einer teilzeit wir haben irgendwie
arbeit die so schlecht entlohnt wird
dass leute auf hartz4 noch aufstocken
müssen damit sie überhaupt auf ein
existenzminimum kommen und ich würde es
ähnlich wie sie das würde ich noch
irgendwie weiter ausführen ich würde
lieber flexibilisieren und
liberalisieren auf der arbeiter seite
dass wir dort die möglichkeit haben dass
beispielsweise
renteneintritt flexibel gestaltet werden
kann so wie es für frauen für familien
für männer für berufseinsteiger halt gut
ist und diese flexibilität
beispielsweise die ausgestaltung von
home office beispielsweise irgendwie
tausend andere facetten in der
berufswelt die fehlt und diese
flexibilisierung von den arbeitgebern zu
den arbeitnehmern also dass dort eine
hat bauermann stattfindet und die dann
die wirkmacht haben das bräuchte ja ich
glaube dass sie da absolut recht haben
aber dass das ja zum glück sowieso
kommen wird also was wir jetzt haben ist
eine umkehrung der machtverhältnisse
also wenn jetzt arbeitnehmer plötzlich
händeringend gesucht werden das hatten
wir ja nun schon als phänomen dann ist
ja klar dass jetzt die arbeitnehmer also
die beschäftigten bestimmen können wie
der arbeitsplatz aussieht also wenn man
jetzt künftig als unternehmer noch
jemanden anheuern will und er sagt ja
aber ich arbeite nur wenn ich hoffe das
kriege dann wird sich der unternehmer
sehr sagen okay dann mach mal home
office wenn das der einzige weg ist
dicht zu halten die leute werden mehr
verdienen automatisch also der
mindestlohn von 12 euro der wird uns
breit schon als lächerlich erscheinen
weil jeder mehr verdient
so also dass diese freie dieses reich
der freiheit kommt das muss man aber
nicht staatlich subventionieren um das
noch mal
sammeln ideen dass er genau wissen nicht
jedes detail ausdiskutieren parade mag
uns natürlich ein wichtiges argument
also ich glaube dass die
flughafenarbeiter noch mal ganz kurz da
gibt es eine ganze menge leute die
wirklich wenig verdienen und wenn man
die löhne entsprechend erhöht könnte es
vielleicht mehr leute geben aber es ist
nicht das einzige instrument es sind
jetzt gerade in nrw ich glaube die
pflege leute an der uni kliniken
streiken derzeit neun wochen und zwar
nicht für mehr lohn sondern für mehr
personal die sagen ihr könnt uns mehr
lohn ist schön aber was wir brauchen ist
jemand der in der nachtschicht oder
irgendwie in dem was war das notarzt mit
mir zusammen das macht auch in den
altenheimen das heißt wir müssen über
bessere arbeitsbedingungen
reden nicht nur über lohn- und teilweise
über komplett andere strukturen ohne
digitalisierung dabei ist wo
arbeitsbedingungen besser sind und die
leute zufrieden damit sind dann müssen
eine uniklinik andere finanziell anders
ausgestattet werden aber nicht um
millionen das sind wir sind an einem
spannenden punkt also wir sind ja bei
der frage welche potenziale in der
gesellschaft können wir nutzen und ich
merke es geht ganz stark aus ihrer sicht
über anreize also es muss für mich
attraktiv seien dort zu arbeiten wo
jemand gesucht wird
und ich habe hier auch von stefan geier
die frage warum wird das nicht einfach
durch den markt geregelt ansteigen der
löhne gehälter darauf haben sie im
grunde die antwort gegeben also ich
selbst kürzlich ein unternehmer
getroffen der auch 20 euro für
ungelernte bezahlt und trotzdem keine
findet also aber die botschaft ist ja es
gibt sicherlich auch bereiche wo das
anders ist aber viele unternehmen locken
schon mit guten löhnen
sie sollen home office anbieten haben
sie gesagt sie haben die kinderbetreuung
genannt frage müssen unternehmen so wie
es früher teilweise üblich war wieder
lernen sagt mal kinderbetreuung im
betrieb anzurichten vielleicht wohnungen
zu kaufen damit menschen aus mecklenburg
vorpommern nach münchen ziehen und dort
bei mir arbeiten können also ist das
teil der umkehrung die wir erleben
hurricanes das handelsblatt hatte seit
einigen jahren eine eigene kita aus
genau dem grund ob man das bei wohnungen
auch anfangen muss ich glaube das gibt
es auch schon dass das jetzt dass das
dass es die ersten werks siedlungen
wieder gibt also sowie im ruhrgebiet vor
100 jahren dass dann der der der schlug
baron neben der zeche noch die die
siedlung baut neulich hab gelesen
betrieb unser land der ingenieure
braucht imitat wohnungen gekauft und so
also ich glaub nicht also ich kann es
jetzt nicht auf eine einzelne maßnahme
runterbrechen aber das sind dann
generell man mit dem mit dem
arbeitsplatz als arbeitgeber ein
gesamtpaket anbieten muss und dieses
gesamtpaket muss stimmen und da kann die
kita mit dabei sein da kann vielleicht
auch in ausnahmefällen mal die wohnung
mit dabei sein da muss das gehalt
stimmen und dann muss natürlich auch so
banal es klingt die die wertschätzung im
job und die arbeit die man macht die
muss halt auch stimmt das meist aber wir
kommen in einen wettbewerb zwischen
unternehmen wo die starken das leisten
können aber was ist mit den vielen
kleinbetrieben wo jemand vielleicht ein
zwei drei vier fünf sechs sieben leute
hat ja ich muss ja sagen wir sind wir in
deutschland auch zu erfolgsverwöhnt es
gab unter personalern die maßnahme die
mit post and pray beschrieben wurde das
heißt sie schalten einer stellenanzeige
und beten und früher wurden der gebete
erhöhtes gabe bewerbungen in großer zahl
sie haben die zeit auch von
stellenausschreibungen bis zur
einstellung sehr schnell überwunden und
mittlerweile um in diesem bild zu
bleiben werden gebeten nicht mehr so
das heißt sie haben weniger bewerbungen
die qualität sinkt und die zeit ist
länger und das erste was man doch
eigentlich machen muss sich überlegen
warum sollte sich jemand dort bewerb
warum sollte sich jemand bei mir
bewerben und welche maßnahmen fördere
ich marketing aber auch tatsächlich
glaubwürdige
glaubwürdige grundstrukturen an zu
zeigen dass es sich lohnt für mich zu
arbeiten und das macht ja kaum ein okay
ich würde gerne ja also ist es spannend
ich habe im blick und würde gerne weiter
kommen wir haben gesagt bei all dem was
wir tun wird das wahrscheinlich nicht
ausreichen sondern die frage wie
gewinnen der menschen die in anderen
ländern leben wird eine zentrale frage
sein als brücke dahin
freimanis leben ja sehr viele menschen
aus anderen ländern bei uns denen das
arbeiten extrem schwer gemacht wird
entweder weil sie ihn wieder so schön
heißt bildung sind und abenteuerliche
bürokratische prozesse mit ihrem
arbeitgeber durchstehen müssen
aber selbst die die offiziell arbeiten
dürfen ukrainerin ukraine erzählen die
geschichten also kennen die geschichte
von dem lkw fahrer aus der ukraine der
jahrelang für eine litauische firma
durch europa gefahren ist und hier jeder
autobahn kennt jetzt ist in ostwestfalen
gestrandet und würde gerne von deutschen
betriebenen gleiche tun das darf er
nicht weil ihm dazu irgendwelche
qualifikationen fehlen also meine über
frage ist was ist zunächst mal bevor
weitere kommen mit denen die hier sind
und arbeiten also als er sie haben
völlig recht das ist natürlich eine
zwingend wäre die flüchtlinge die da
sind oder auch die geduldeten in den
arbeitsmarkt zu integrieren und in
natürlich gibt es diese ganzen
geschichten aber man muss sagen dass das
zum teil auch schon gelingt also ich hab
das extra noch mal nachgesehen 460.000
flüchtlinge und asylanten arbeiten schon
in sozialversicherungspflichtigen
gerufen also die nicht irgendwie als
minijob oder als aushilfen oder sonstwas
sondern ganz regulär natürlich gibt es
jetzt noch 401 1000 die offiziell
arbeitslos sind die man auch noch
integrieren muss und will davon sind
aber viele schon in irgendwelchen
ausbildungsmaßnahmen das heißt
eigentlich läuft dieser prozess schon am
dunkelsten sieht es aus bei den
geduldeten das sind 1 menschen die
eigentlich in ihre heimatländer zurück
sollen aber dort gar nicht hin können da
ist es wohl irgendwie sagen wir mal
220.000 geduldeten gelungen erst 8000 in
den sogenannten spurwechsel zu
transportieren spurwechsel heißt okay du
bist geduldet darfst aber trotzdem
arbeiten und da sieht man natürlich dass
da noch ein riesen potenzial ist aber
insgesamt die statistiken sind alle sehr
mühsam würde ich mal sagen sind handelt
es sich im augenblick um 600.000
menschen die man doch in
beschäftigung bringen könnte das muss
man unbedingt tun aber ich glaube die
idee
wenn wir alle flüchtlinge arbeiten
würden dann hätten wir kein problem mehr
die ist falsch nicht das ist auch nur
eines von vielen segmenten
stichwort frauen oder so wo man
versuchen könnte das potenzial besser
auszunutzen
das was sie angesprochen haben dieses
dass man das
zertifikat nicht bei bringt ist ein sehr
deutsches problem das man für alles was
man kann immer mindestens ein papier
mitbringen muss also 60 prozent noch
einen auch dass man gerade nicht hat
genau und dann muss das wenn man mit
wenn man mit einem zeugnis aus der
ukraine kommt 60 prozent der ukrainerin
haben keinen berufsabschluss dann muss
das beglaubigt werden übersetzt werden
dann müssen noch weitere papiere kommen
und dieser zertifizierung waren dass man
immer alles genau nachgewiesen hat ist
definitiv ein hemmnis also in dänemark
macht man das teilweise anders wir haben
das mal besucht da trifft man leute die
werden als cnc maschine gesetzt dann
kriegt man drei monate lang guckt man
dann ob das geht oder ob das klappt
nicht und dann ist das ein cnc fräser
denn es kann da macht man nicht sechs
monate ausbildungen drei wochen
prüfungen wo ist das papier und was
haben sie vorher gemacht sondern wer es
kann der kampf der lkw-fahrer den müsste
man demnach den sie eben
mal veranlassen und beifahrer
nebensätzen sagen der kann das und dann
fährt er ja welche nicht sätze zu fügen
also genauso ist es ein bisschen mehr
pragmatismus tate uns darauf gut
und das ist ja auch vor allen dingen im
interesse der geflüchteten dass wir
diesen pragmatismus zeigen aber auch da
glaube ich auch dass es kann nur ein
ganz kleiner mosaikstein sein bei der
lösung des gesamtpublikums erinnern ein
einsatz noch einschieben es ist nicht
nur ein problem der politik und der
anerkennung der berufsabschlüsse ist ist
ein albtraum aber es ist auch etwas was
also dieser zeugnis waren der ist nicht
nur ein alleinstellungsmerkmal der
politik sondern auch der wirtschaft wenn
sie sich anschauen wie einfach es ist
als quereinsteiger in einen betrieb zu
gelangen das ist gar nicht so einfach
weil häufig arbeitgeber und arbeitgeber
sehr unsicher sind menschen berufsfremde
oder qualifikations fremd einzustellen
und es auszuprobieren und da muss auch
auf der arbeitgeberseite ein umdenken in
der kulturstadt okay jetzt bei allem was
ich frage sagen sie ja das ist ein
mosaikstein aber das reicht noch nicht
die bundesanstalt für arbeit so heißt
sie nicht mehr die arbeit und die
bundesagentur für arbeit heißt er geht
davon aus dass ihr über all das hinaus
400.000 menschen im jahre gewinnen
müssten die in den deutschen
arbeitsmarkt kommen in guten jahren sind
im moment nicht mal die hälfte
ja ist das dann ist das dann der
entscheidende schritt zur lösung und
warum gelingt uns das nicht jetzt haben
sie ja die was ich will jetzt nicht als
ausländerbeauftragter hier sprechen aber
jetzt haben sie ja die
demographie kurve gerade alle angestellt
und da gibt es zwei möglichkeiten
entweder es werden unglaublich viel mehr
kinder geboren die dann in 20 30 40
jahren voll in den beruf einsteigen
können oder wir holen menschen die hier
noch nicht sind das die schnellere
möglichkeit und wir werden ja zum glück
auch keine mutter mit aromen mehr
verteilen das heißt wir müssen auf
einwanderungen setzen jetzt haben wir 19
73 gesagt wir machen erstmal
anwerbestopp und dann kam lange nichts
und dann sind leute und auch teilweise
forciert durch karmann und arbeitgeber
über den asyl weg hier nach deutschland
gekommen was dann 1990 dazu geführt hat
dass den leuten aufgefallen dass oder
sind ja ganz viel scheinasylanten und
deshalb nichts passiert dann gab es
unterschiedliche beweggründe und
dann sind zwei dinge passiert das haben
sie gerade gesagt hätte
dass wir uns auf die fachkräfte gestürzt
haben diese hochqualifizierten oder
irgendwie die sofortprogramme für leute
mit und jetzt haben wir auch einen
fachkräfte einwanderungsgesetz seit 2009
10 und da stellen wir fest dass die
leute am gepäckband die abfertigung
machen denn der gastronomie im tourismus
das müssen ja gar keine fachkräfte seien
es fehlen ja überall leute ja und diese
idee dass wir sagen wir brauchen mehr
menschen die nach deutschland kommt hier
arbeiten und leben und sesshaft werden
und mit uns gemeinsam den wohlstand
aufbauen das hat sich doch keine partei
getraut in den letzten 40 jahren
stattdessen wir in unterschiedlichen
chorgesängen das boot ist voll gesungen
ja wir haben vor vier jahren noch
überlegt ob der islam zu deutschland
gehört das bleibt ja nicht irgendwie
unbeobachtet auch im ausland also wir
müssen da auch kulturell und emotional
und erzählerisch eine andere story
anwerfen um überhaupt in irgendeiner
weise in deutschland begreifbar zu
machen es müssen menschen auch aus der
türkei auch aus muslimischen ländern
hierher kommen um mit uns gemeinsam
diese wirtschaft am laufen gerade da
muss man sagen da hat sich jetzt
tatsächlich mit der ampel koalition ein
bisschen etwas geändert ich glaube dass
die erste bundesregierung ja wirklich
offiziell sagt wir müssen ein
einwanderung sein du bist halt gucken ob
das was bringt allein damit dass man
erklärt wird es wahrscheinlich nicht
besser aber
zumindest städte der mine zettels glaube
ich erstmals da nun leben wir in einer
gesellschaft ist nicht nur bei uns so
ist den meisten gesellschaften so wo der
eine teil offen ist für neue fremde
menschen und einladend und das als
gewinn empfindet wo ein anderer teil was
gibt dass die hälfte ist aber jedenfalls
ein erheblicher teil sagt ich möchte
nicht dass meine kultur verändert wird
und dass mehr fremde menschen kommt das
ist realität nicht nur in unserer
gesellschaft
ist das das größte hindernis für
rademacher oder dass wir eigentlich
werben und platz hätten und niemand
kommt wir sind in der attraktivität in
der oecd liste wie attraktives
deutschland für zuhörer noch auf platz
zwölf das ist ziemlich weit unter
unserer unter anderem aus diesem grund
weil der latente und offenen rassismus
leute die vor allem in einer anderen
hautfarbe jährigen kommen ich meine
ukrainerin und kreieren haben halt die
richtige hautfarbe die da ist das auch
wesentlich einfacher offensichtlich sie
auf den arbeitsmarkt zu schicken das ist
ein riesenproblem
es ist ein riesiges gesellschaft wird
problem ich glaube dass die
demografische krise uns irgendwann da
vorstellen wird macht der betrieb zu
macht das pflegeheim die bäckerei oder
auch der automobilzulieferer zu oder
kommen menschen aus afrika mit anderen
farben mit anderer religion und werden
hier integriert und werden als
arbeitskräfte akzeptiert wir dürfen
nicht vergessen spanien portugal
frankreich ein bisschen alle anderen
ländern haben das gleiche problem die
wollen auch leute haben wir stehen nicht
nur in konkurrenz zu irgendwas wir
stehen in konkurrenz in europa dazu mehr
leute zu bekommen und um zwei zwar gehen
die damit besser um also da haben wir
riesen nachholbedarf das ist eine
politische gesellschaftliche frage daran
zu arbeiten
ja also die das interessante ist dass es
schrank mir wirklich wichtig dass die
ausländerfeindlichkeit oder auch dieser
rassismus besonders stark in gebieten
ist wo gar keine ausländer leben also
weil ähnliches jahr ein bekanntes aber
das sollte man immer wieder betonen dass
die leute angst vor ausländern haben die
gar keine ausländer kennen so weil sonst
das immer so als scheinbar rational
wirken könnte ist natürlich die gegenden
sind wo menschen abwandern wo es weniger
aber wo die löhne schlechter so genau
also es gibt ja wahrscheinlich viele
gründe warum die dann rassisten sind
aber ein punkt ist wichtig sie haben
noch nie ein ausländer gesehen und das
ist machbar betont das ist
genau weil klar ist dass dann nicht die
ausländer in das problem sind sondern
dass heimische gründe so jetzt ich
glaube dass das was schon gesagt wurde
ganz wichtig ist man muss sich klar
machen dass aus europa die einen dann
daran nicht kommen können die eu ist
ausgeschöpft alle anderen länder auch
rumänien bulgarien und so weiter haben
die gleichen demografischen probleme das
heißt wenn man zu wir haben lange unsere
probleme gelöst die eben genau es gab er
die freizügigkeit und dann hat sich ganz
rumänien bulgarien diese länder sich
entleert aber da gibt es auch keine
jugendlichen die geboren worden wären
das heißt wenn man zuwanderung will das
brust ganz klar kommuniziert werden dann
sind die großen chancen im nahen osten
also irak beispielsweise oder eben auch
in afrika und darauf und das muss allen
klar sein und das ist eben eigentlich
auch gar nicht gar kein problem denn wie
gesagt da wo schon ausländer leben sind
ja eigentlich alle ganz zufrieden was
ich aber doch gerne ansprechen würde das
wäre mir wichtig ist dass ich glaube
dass die deutschen sich auch mit einer
völlig anderen form der technisierung
werden demnächst auseinander setzen
müssen weil ein möglichkeit diesen
mangel an arbeitskräften zu kompensieren
ist ja dass man den kunden zur
mitarbeiter macht also beispielsweise
aus zusätzlich kassiere selbst oder ganz
plastisch es gibt keine hotelrezeption
mir nichts sondern man muss sich da
selber einchecken und wer das nicht
versteht kann leider nicht mehr ins
hotel also dass er wird zunehmen durch
pakete werden digital aufgerissen und
nicht von dem mitarbeiter ergeben haben
roboter installieren weil er bei den sb
kassen werde ich immer so ein bisschen
zornig weil ich immer das gefühl aber
naja ich stehe ja genau so lange in der
schlange wie wenn ein kassierer sitzen
[Musik]
also ich denke es geht längst technische
system wo man einfach den vollen
einkaufswagen durch ein scanner portal
schiebt und dann wird vollautomatisch
angezeigt was in den einkaufswagen liegt
das wäre alles überhaupt kein problem
wenn eben ein bisschen mehr investiert
würde soll hatten schon so gehen kann
ich meine schleißheimer zeugt er kommt
sein ich möchte gerne mit blick auf die
uhr also ich bin ihnen sehr dankbar ich
finde wir haben viele facetten einer
möglichen lösung geschildert also haben
sie sagen eine lange liste von
möglichkeiten gemacht wir haben ein
ganzes problem beschrieben haben
deutlich gemacht wie viel versäumnis ist
da auch gibt ich würde gerne zum schluss
mit ihnen bundeskabinett spielen und
jeder und jede von ihnen kann sich ein
ressort aussuchen und sagen was sie
nächste woche im kabinett als vorschlag
einbringen würden weil sie glauben das
muss jetzt und schnell und so passieren
wer möchte anfangen das ist eine
schwierige aufgabe das gewicht zu aber
sagen sie an irgend ja ich würde sagen
die würde die die abschreibungs fristen
für
investitionen rationalisierung und
automatisierung drastisch verkürzen als
finanzminister da können sie sicher da
können sie sich jetzt aussuchen welcher
minister ich das mache gerne als
bundeskanzler und auf diese weise ist
eben für für für unternehmen aber auch
für behörden kliniken massiv attraktiver
machen arbeit zu automatisieren und zu
rationalisieren weil arbeit ist ja kein
selbstzweck es ist ja nicht so dass wir
vielen dank herr herrmann ja also ich
bin dann auch finanzministerin aber von
der anderen partei ich würde sagen das
ist völliger unsinn dass man jetzt
originäre aber aufgaben der unternehmer
nämlich zu investieren steuerlich
fördert also sondern was machen sie ja
also ich finde das gut wenn man jetzt
tatsächlich etwas bewegen hat in diesen
zertifikate wahnsinn deutlich reduzieren
würde ich bin also arbeitsministerin sie
sorgen dafür dass jeder erst mal
ausprobieren darf und genau das hat
dänemark modell hat mir total der
beratungen eingenommen dann bin ich
jetzt frauenministerin und möchte gerne
dass meine geschlechtsgenossinnen die
möglichkeit bekommen sich selber
aussuchen ob sie nicht 20 prozent oder
50 prozent und 70 prozent arbeiten es
gibt ein teilzeit das gesetzt das
erlaubt das sprich ehegattensplitting
abschaffen menge jobs abschaffen nur
noch für rentnerinnen und studierenden
per anfang an ich kann ja alles aus und
ich werde natürlich bildungsminister und
werde dafür sorgen dass
bildungsgerechtigkeit ein zug hält plus
natürlich auch unsere kinder und
jugendlichen fit gemacht werden für
autonomie sierung auto losfahren
effizienzsteigerungen die entwicklung
von drohnen und robotern die uns
menschen möglich festlegen und da werde
ich regelmäßig mit meinen kabinetts
kolleginnen die hier ganz wunderbar sind
die nieren und genau das müssen sie alle
nur auch gewählt werden sind wir sind
wir einige schritte weiter bedanke mich
sehr herzlich wenn sie in der ard dabei
sind dann jetzt das europamagazin mit
einer reportage aus kiew in der ukraine
sonst bei phoenix im radio presseclub
nachgefragt
bedanke mich für interesse wünsche ihnen
weiterhin einen wunderschönen sonntag
lassen sie es gut finden
[Musik]
und willkommen zurück presseclub
nachgefragt im fernsehen bei phoenix im
radio bei wdr 5 und
wir beginnen in bad münder am deister
bei eric bei erika auf der hardt
willkommen in der sendung sie haben das
wort
sowie angefangen beim hauptschüler wird
belächelt aber es wird total vergessen
dass es gerade ohne die arbeiter in der
wirtschaft nicht geht diese müssten mehr
wertgeschätzt werden dann brauchen wir
auch keine fremde weiter meine meinung
vielen herzlichen dank dafür
aspekt über den ich auch viel gelesen
habe also wie verhindert unser
schulsystem dass menschen die richtigen
anreize haben glaubt man braucht ja also
ich glaube dass diese beobachtung völlig
richtig ist dass also im raum blickt man
vor allen dingen viel wert ist wenn man
studiert hat ich glaube aber dass ich
das auch ändern könnte denn wenn
handwerker so knapp sind wir jetzt also
beispielsweise wenn man eine wärmepumpe
einbauen will findet man ja niemanden
oder eine solaranlage auf dem dach haben
will findet sich keiner die sind
ausgelastet in den nächsten zehn jahren
dann ist ja ganz klar dass die löhne da
auch sehr stark steigen und es ist schon
heute so dass handwerker in wahrheit
zwar nie wenn sie meister sind mehr
verdienen als durchschnittliche
akademiker und das wird sich irgendwann
auch mal rumsprechen also ich glaube
dass der mangel dazu führen wird dass
der handwerker beruf aufgewertet wird
danke frau fda hat alles gute bis bald
ja ich kann es trier ist die nächste
station möchte gottes willkommen sie
haben das wort
[Musik]
ich weiß von vielen meiner kollegen die
nach
walldorf viel besser bezahlt wird ich
weiß von leuten aus dem
behindertenbereich
doch die ebenfalls der weg nach
luxemburg geht und ich habe auch schon
von handwerkern gehört dass auf dieser
weg dorthin bestritten
von daher tat dies auf das ist aber
nicht ganz neu das war schon zu hören
nur unsere arbeitgeber haben
offensichtlich nicht darauf reagiert da
sind diese hoffnung selbst wenn es einen
mangel gibt automatisch die söhne
hochgeklappt mich nicht mehr dran man
nimmt ein im grunde genommen kommt
wahrscheinlich sehr viele jetzt auch im
osten für die werden irgendwann auch
kapieren dass
ich habe der kernsatz war sie sagen sie
glauben nicht daran dass der anreiz die
hören die für höhere löhne sagte
rademacher also die löhne in der pflege
sind in den letzten jahren schon
deutlich gestiegen für die helfer
berufen wie für die qualifizierte berufe
ich glaube dass man in der pflege und im
krankenhaus vor allem aber an andere
strukturen denken muss also niederlanden
gibt es ein modell namens bord sorgt das
quasi hierarchie frei ist es sind kleine
gruppen von menschen die vor allem sich
um alte und pflegebedürftige kümmern
solange sie zu hause sind und wo die
gesamte digitalisierung also das
abrechnen und so was wird alles in
externen und gemacht und die
arbeitsbedingungen sind deutlich besser
und ich glaube dass man wenn man die
leute behalten will es nicht nur darum
geht das ist dass es mehr löhne gibt
gerade in der pflege sondern dass man
über andere bessere arbeitsbedingungen
andere modelle redet wo fliegen sie
wieder zudem kommen was sie eigentlich
machen wollen menschen unterstützen und
helfen nicht nur abfertigen das ist
glaube ich die chance die darin liegt
dass man sich da noch mal umorientiert
folgert dass ich bin ehrlich gesagt auch
gespannt ja also das haben sie auch
erlebt die löhne sind deutlich gestiegen
aber sie sind nicht da dass mehr frauen
und männer sagen denn job mache ich
gerne bin mal gespannt jetzt die
pandemie hat das ein bisschen
unterbrochen jetzt haben wir inflation
und spannende tarifverhandlungen also
werden wir alle miteinander beobachten
wie das sich auf die lohnentwicklung
auswirkt danke dass sie dabei sind groß
nach trier und wir springen nach
senftenberg zu kerstin weidner bekommen
schon dass sie angerufen haben
sind also ich habe meine ganz mutige
frage und zwar stelle ich das hier
meiner umgebung setzt haben wir nicht
ein generationsproblem weil bei uns
beschwert sich eltern immer mehr dass
ihre kinder nicht mehr so in die
arbeitswelt wollen wie die damals die
haben das muss ich wirklich so sagen
schlechte arbeitsbedingungen gehabt
vielleicht löhne gehabt denn jetzt
kaputt auf den knochen kommt praktisch
nicht mehr weiter krise rente und da
sagen die kinder klipp und klar das
wollen wir nicht so das ist erstmal die
erste problem provokante frage also dass
wir sozusagen
nicht drüber gebracht haben dass arbeit
spaß machen kann das wichtig ist dass
wenn wir uns jetzt hier nicht bewegen da
trat im still steht und dann noch eine
zweite frage sie reden auch immer was
ich festgestellt habe immer von sehr
hohen berufsgruppen ich nehme jetzt mal
den einfachen koch dass wir den kindern
auch nicht beibringen jetzt kann sich
jeder ein drei sterne koch sein aber
trotzdem mit seiner arbeit wichtig die
alle wollen in gaststätten gehen nicht
nur in gehobene gaststätten sondern in
normale wir wollen den kantinenessen
gehen wir wollen in pflegeheimen das
essen haben schön wäre es sogar
schulessen wieder zu schaffen aber dann
müssen die leute dort auch bezahlt
werden und vor allen dingen anerkannt
werden oftmals ist es doch an uns
erwachsenen selber dass wir
berufsgruppen acht gewertet raum und
jetzt wundern wir uns dass da praktisch
schlechter ruf ist und ich gebe der frau
rakers recht rademaker precht es ist
nicht immer die bezahlung gerade in der
pflege hat sich viel getan aber es ist
die arbeitsbedingung die die frauen
erschöpfen nacken männer erschöpfen
lassen dass sie eher und ihren berufen
müssen dass sie in praktische pflege
vermissten an sich am meer am menschen
selbst und
bürokratie und wir hören immer
bürokratieabbau bürger arbeitspaketen
und gehen ihnen sehr dankbar vielen
herzlichen dank dass sie haben den
finger in die wunde gelegt hätten frau
wissen und her gerissen denn ich finde
einzig wenn junge leute sagen ich tue
mir ist nicht mehr an so wie meine
eltern generation sich die knochen
kaputt zu machen für einen schlecht
bezahlten job dann ist das ja erst mal
eine nicht ganz falsche erkenntnis und
und sie haben das richtige wort gesagt
das hängt ja vor allen dingen auch an an
wertschätzung im beruf also die frage ob
ich als koch gerne arbeite oder nicht
hängt natürlich an gehalt aber haben wir
davon ausgeht es gibt einen tarifgehalt
als koch ob ich in einer küche gerne
arbeite oder nicht hängt wahrscheinlich
zu 90 prozent davon ab wieder das klima
ist in dieser küche ob ich gut behandelt
werde ob ich wertgeschätzt werde ob ich
gelobt werde oder ob ich eben einen
despotischen chef habe der mich herum
scheucht und ich das gefühl habe woche
mache ich das ja eigentlich und ich
glaube da ist auch der himmel für für
kleine unternehmen die sich vielleicht
das eben nicht leisten können jeden
gehalts schritt mitzugehen zu sagen ja
ok aber dafür bist du bei uns teil des
teams teil der familie du wirst
wertgeschätzt
du weißt jeden tag warum du hier bist
verarbeiten dann nochmal genau wir haben
genau die finger in die wunde gelegt
heute nehme ich noch sagen ganz oft ist
das thema mobbing mobbing gerade bei
älteren arbeitskräften weil sie zu teuer
sind nicht nicht weil die nicht können
sondern weil sie wieder mal finanziell
gedacht zu teuer sind
mobbing ist ganz groß hier in meinem
umfeld wo ich sage dass viele ältere
arbeitgeber den tag angehen wo die als
erstes in rente gehen weil wird sich
einmal beschwert dass viele zu schnell
in rente gehen das hat ursachen damit
man hingucken das muss nicht sein die
wollen gerne weiterarbeiten
aber wenn ich gemobbt werde dann gegen
dann will ich das nicht frau bei vielen
herzlichen dank das waren spannende
austausch gruß nach senftenberg wir ja
wir gehen weiter zu andreas jannis aus
neunkirchen seelscheid hallo hallo guten
tag
in die runde
ich habe eine ganz andere wahrnehmung
der arbeitsmarktpolitik die letzten fünf
jahre ich habe zwei berufsausbildungen
ich hab's musikstudium meine letzte
längere beschäftigung war als
kirchenmusiker die ich dann
gesundheitsbedingt aufgegeben habe ich
hatte vor drei jahren noch eine
lehrervertretung stelle für musik und
technik an einer gesamt zu danach fallen
die stunden wieder aus lehrerstellen
gibt es im rhein sieg kreis überhaupt
keine freundin nicht im quereinstieg es
gibt mal lehrervertretung stellen wenn
ich mich auf verwaltungsstellen bewerbe
weil ich auch eine verwaltungsausbildung
habe bewerben streich 400 leute und ich
mit 58 falle hinten ab ich habe viele
fähigkeiten ich habe auch eine schlaufe
ausbildung im handwerklichen bereich
möchte ich nicht unbedingt aufgrund
meines alters mehr arbeiten aber in der
verwaltung sie es mich und ich sehe mich
auch in der schule wenn ich nur rein
käme und die kommen nicht rein und ich
sage ihnen ich habe eine andere
erfahrung wenn ich ein handwerker
braucht wo ich den anderen kommt er
vorbei die sache erledigt und nur ein
problem wie am flughafen das ist
hausgemacht dass wir haben heuer ein
freier in deutschland die leute sehen
vor der parte mir ausgeschnitten und
gekonntem ist zu ende und dann suchen
sie die leute wieder das ist alles eine
arbeitsmarktpolitik die ganz schlecht
verwaltet wird ich habe das auch die
mehrheit schriebe der herr heil hat auch
geantwortet ich habe zuletzt gemehrt
geschrieben der antwortet überhaupt
nicht seit drei wochen
er hat wahrscheinlich kann die karte
oder auch keine lust meine fragen zu
beantworten ob er hat noch ein paar
andere themen gerade her gerne isst ich
find's klasse wie engagiert sie sind
danke dass sie uns ihre perspektive
gestellt haben was nicht an tage
angesetzt ich denke es kommen hier
unterschiedliche sachen zusammen das
eine ist die anerkennung von
berufsfremden qualifikationen wir haben
ja gerade über quereinsteiger geredet
und ob wir uns trauen sowohl in der
politik als seine verwaltung als auch in
der privatindustrie
solche menschen eine chance zu geben es
kann auch sein dass ein anderes thema
dazu kommt das kann ich jetzt ohne die
genaue anders als genau ansehen des
falls nicht sagen aber wir haben ein
thema mit altersdiskriminierung auf dem
arbeitsmarkt
und tatsächlich ist es aber auch so dass
in manchen gegenden natürlich der
arbeitskräftemangel größer ist als in
anderen dh es gibt natürlich gegenden wo
viele bewerberinnen und bewerber auf
eine position kommen und andere gegen
dann jetzt mecklenburg vorpommern hat
genannt aber die ballungsräume wo es
sich umgekehrt
ich denke sehe ich irgendwie frau
herrmann das wird sich insgesamt
nivellieren wir werden insgesamt alle
gleichermaßen katastrophe
hineinschlittern und das wird sich
darstellen aber es ist auch an den
arbeitgeberinnen und arbeitgebern da
mehr flexibilität und auch einen anderen
blick so zu sagen danke mich herzlich
herr yannis alles gute für sie drücke
ihnen die daumen
und wir sind in eberbach in baden gute
hoffmann hat uns angerufen freue mich
dass sie dabei sind sie haben das wort
ja wohl und war habe ich eine erfahrung
gemacht ich war in jugoslawien in urlaub
und man kommt ja dann mit dem volk in
kontakt und dann
hatte ich alle niemand auf dem
campingplatz der sprache hervorragend
deutsch dann fragte ich aber habe sie
die deutschkenntnisse hier das sagte sie
sie war kriegsflüchtling und war in
deutschland hätte gern in deutschland
gearbeitet aber sie wurde rausgeworfen
in maßen findet das war dass sie war
also in einem billig sektor beschäftigt
das war friseur und
der arbeitgeber hatte sich ein gesetz
das sie da bleiben kann und die wurde
dann einfach rausgeworfen ist kein
kriegsflüchtling mehr wir haben kein
bedarf mehr
angehen und landete in deutschland ist
diese bürokratie wir haben leute die
sich integrieren wollen die sich
engagieren wollen die betriebe die sie
halten wollen und werfen programm raus
da muss abgebaut werden ok ich würde es
einfach vielen dank frau hoffmann war
das einfach als appell stehen lassen wir
haben das thema in der sendung ja auch
schon gehabt aber ich versuche mal
möglichst viele stimmen zu wort kommen
zu lassen aus schipkau ruft helmut leben
an perli man guten tag guten tag in die
runde ich hab irgendwann
schließlich
kommt die andere kam und zwar die
generation praktikum
da hat man ja die weiter ausgenutzt und
viele wollen
und hat man sie ja in gestellt weil sie
habe die arbeitskräfte waren
und dann jetzt hier mit halb vier dann
gab es ja mal jährige über lehrgänge
dann 14 tage praktikum
und das wars stand wieder gewesen also
effizient wollen das nicht das hat zwar
die
arbeitslosenstatistik verbessert aber
die menschen die dahinter stehen nicht
es war ein risiko ist rausgeschmissenes
geld und jetzt wo man geld braucht für
die leute weil die total falsch
ausgebildet wohl nicht richtig gemacht
haben und dann werde die leute den mut
verloren und dann wird dort
nicht mehr ein weil ihm die vielen
herzlichen dank botschaft ist angekommen
war hermann generation praktiker würde
ich gern nochmal aufgreifen
in der tat ist es ja nicht lange her
dass wir drüber gesprochen haben das ist
für junge menschen nur zeitverträge und
keine festen jobs gibt ja also das ist
auch so ein phänomen ist war immer klar
das wurde ja hier auch schon gesagt dass
eigentlich bald nicht demografische
lücke da sein würde weil mehr baby
boomer in die rente gehen als
jugendliche nachwachsen aber das konnte
sich niemand vorstellen vor allem die
eltern dieser jugendlichen konnten sich
das nicht vorstellen weil die baby
boomer selbst haben das ja immer erlebt
dass sie zu viele sind da sie arbeitslos
sind und so weiter und dann wurde ein
enormer druck auf die jugendlichen
ausgeübt ihr müsst praktika machen ihr
müsst ganz schnell studieren er sonst
kriegt ihr keine stelle so und jetzt
stellen diese jugendlichen fest dass
ihre eltern sich geirrt haben und ich
glaube und das ist wirklich eine menge
stellen für sie gibt und ich glaube das
ist auch so eine reaktion das kam ja
auch in senftenberg schon vor dass die
jugend sagt nee das also diese art von
druck wollen wir nicht und das ist aber
auch ein druck den die eltern gemacht
haben weil sie es selbst anders erlebt
haben danke schön ich habe zum schluss
verrate marca wir haben nur noch wenige
sekunden aber das thema rentenalter ist
eines das ich hier im chat in vielen
rückmeldungen sehr
werden wir uns leisten können weiterhin
durchschnittlich mit 64 in rente zu
gehen
nein werden wir nicht sondern es muss
versucht werden dass es eine aufgabe der
politik und auch der wirtschaft dass man
das menschen tatsächlich daran heran
geführt werden dass sie das reguläre
renteneintrittsalter erreichen das wäre
in meinem fall zumal bei fast 67 dass
man in der industrie zum beispiel den
menschen das erleichtert weniger schicht
ab 60 ab 20 ab 63 einen tag frei dass
man modelle findet technische
unterstützung des menschen mindestens
das reguläre renteneintrittsalter
erreichen ich halte nichts davon rente
mit 70 oder mit 80 zu machen dass viele
leute nicht daran glaube ich noch mal
als separates thema wenn ich all die
rückmeldungen sehe unsere zeit für heute
ist abgelaufen danke für die vielen
klugen argumente und perspektiven und
ihnen ja eine gute woche danke groß aus
köln lassen sich gut gehen
[Musik]